Meek Mill is a rapper and he tweeted out
in response to a rally that V and Trump
were doing together he tweeted out he
said wait till yall see who the black
people in poverty voting for four
exclamation points now what does that
mean it was being reported as an
implicit endorsement of trump I didn't
know I couldn't quite tell how to read
it but then I realized two days ago he
made his political views even clearer he
said Joe Biden is too old to be our
president respectfully WTF is going on
in the American system that y'all
pushing this through like it's okay to
trust what we see in so it's pretty
clear here Meek Mill Mr Mill endorsing
Donald Trump